foreign
Jason is up next in Denver Colorado
Jason welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
going on
well I
committed a financial sin and I financed
the vehicle
and uh my wife wants me to sell it uh
I'm having a little trouble getting it
sold anywhere close to what I paid for I
was wondering if you had any advice on
that and what to do do you think you
should sell it
yes I I believe I probably
shouldn't have bought it
okay so how much was this car
uh 65. what do you owe on the loan
uh I just bought it so it's uh probably
64 right now okay you didn't put
anything down
uh no I I I totally financed it okay and
you have you actually looked at private
party value for this vehicle
yes uh uh it's quite a bit less uh so uh
I'm seeing
54 55
000 for this vehicle how much money do
you have in the bank
uh we don't have a a lot probably about
10 000 in the bank uh I I do have a uh
quite a substantial amount in my uh tsp
or or 401K okay we don't want to touch
retirement so you've got enough that you
could cover the difference on the loan
let's say you sell it for 55 you owe 64.
you'll take nine grand from savings and
it's gonna hurt
but that would cover your stupid tax
you'd be out of this thing now you still
need another car correct yes yes so we
need to save up a little bit more and
get a beater in order to do that and if
you wanted to this is the only time we
would tell you it's okay to take out a
loan is to go to your credit union get a
small loan to cover the difference and
then you can use that to make this all
happen and clean this up
hey okay let me ask you this because the
way you said you committed a financial
sin like here's the thing we all screw
up with money that happens
but had you and your wife agreed that
y'all were not going to borrow money and
yeah we're through
borrowing on cars and you went out and
did this anyway
yes yes uh we had uh been kind of
following uh
the the baby steps and things like that
but I had a vehicle that I was had about
280 000 miles on it and uh I went to get
it uh worked on and stuff and now they
told me how much I was gonna you know
have to spend to get it fixed so I just
I kind of uh got stupid in there and
just went and bought another vehicle
so you said I'm not going to pay for a
three thousand dollar repair haha joke's
on you I'm gonna buy a 65 000 car
that'll show us yeah
okay so here here's what I want you to
do so you obviously did something dumb
with math right you know that
yes
I'm way way more concerned
that with with what we call here
Financial infidelity
you cheated on your wife
Yes Y'all came to a core agreement on
values and who we are gonna be and you
had a toddler moment
where you took your ball and I'm going
home and you bought a 60 you put your
family in jeopardy
so if you haven't already I want you to
go home
and turn all the TV off and all the
Netflix off and I want you to take a
knee in front of your wife and hold both
of her hands and look her in the eye and
say I'm sorry
I violated have you done this done that
already good what'd she say
yes she uh uh I guess she forgave me but
she's still pretty upset yeah both of
those things can be true right she can
forgive you and be really pissed yeah
forgiveness can be instant the healing
process and rebuilding trust that'll
take a while
yeah so cool go sell this car man and
make it right
will do what's your household income
uh I make about 177 uh thousand year uh
my wife probably makes about 50. awesome
you guys have an amazing income
yeah so next month you'll have do you
have any other debt
uh we we own two houses when we got
married I had a house and she had a
house
uh we were talking about selling my
house and uh
and just moving you know uh and just
having this one house I think that's a
great plan could you start to knock
knock down the mortgage once you have
your emergency fund in place and you're
investing could you start to chip away
at the mortgage if you sold that place
oh I think if we sold one of the houses
we could probably pretty close to paying
out the other house which house does she
want to live in
or her house sell yours tell her tonight
we're gonna sell my house
okay that'll show her that you're
serious about this I'm sure your level
of sacrifice I'm gonna sell my truck or
the car I just bought I'm gonna sell the
house and we're gonna unify this thing
once and for all and we're never
touching that again ever getting rid of
this mortgage I'm done with debt and I'm
done not working together as a team
because that's what we signed up for
thanks for the call Jason